[Music]
okay here
we
hello hey before you watch the intro
here uh just want to let you know that
Tuesday because it used to fall on
different days of the week was the last
Thursday before Halloween this coming
Tuesday is the louder with credder
annual Halloween
Spooktacular it's corny we like it that
way we have costume contest rules you
can post pictures of your Halloween
costume
not contest I'm still I have a little
congestion you can send in pictures of
your Halloween costume send it to me on
Instagram or on Twitter with your mug in
hand we have to know that your mug has
to be we have to know it's a costume not
from last year uh using the hashtag
Spooktacular the hashtag is Spooktacular
Tuesday and uh it's usually the most I I
will say it's the day of the year that
isn't a front to those with um
sensibilities of good taste
enjoy
come in my club with
us in
[Music]
[Applause]
my it's a it's a Halloween spectacular
everybody all right Iceman how are you
why are you discriminating against me
well just so you know I can't hear a
whole lot
today
my uh championship college swimmer for
the women's swim team that makes sense
and then we have
uh we have not a joke we
have the tail of the dtia patient
riddled
president and you ain't
[Music]
black I call it the tale of the uh of
the YouTube tra infection
[Music]
Tony I'm
[Applause]
[Music]
scared what I
know know
[Music]
oh glad I didn't even do the Sip cuz I
was so rattled by the fact that between
intros you guys saw a nice view of my
crotch well swing that's what the fans
want I apologize and for people who for
before you start suspecting this is H
this is Tylenol C and flew which I'm
mostly Fine By the way but I took the
wrong I took the wrong thing yes I took
the AL Alka silter there's day and night
I took the day what at night how do you
mess that up I haven't
slept well so uh we have a lot to get to
today obviously look there's been this
incredible I mean this incredibly tragic
and just overwhelming shooting that has
happened in Maine here's the truth it is
10:15 Eastern 9:14 Central Gods time we
don't know everything but we know a lot
we know enough to know that the media is
incorrect so we're going to be talking
about that something that I've I've
wanted to talk about we we teased this
yesterday the truth about the Gaza water
shortage because a lot of people want
you to believe that Israel is just
stopping water from going into Gaza but
this is actually something that will
hopefully be a reference piece for you
because it's something that comes up
every couple of years the idea that the
Palestinian people uh don't have access
to water that that's being shut down
it's not true there are a lot of myths
out there and we really wanted to make
sure that the references were available
for you today also in a more current
format why nobody wants Palestinian
refugees people talk about Israel we've
talked about Egypt but how about we go
through Syria let's go through Jordan
let's go through Lebanon let's go
through uh Saudi Arabia I already
mentioned Egypt did you you corrected me
in run through saying that there was no
access to the Red Sea in Egypt no I
thought you said dead and I was going
hold on a second I don't know a lot of
things but I know shark attacks and I
know that there were shark attacks in
Egypt in the Red
Sea he they were really really bad bad
shark attack so uh we'll get to that and
and more and of course look people will
say oh it's trite but yeah our thoughts
and our prayers really do go out to the
families who've been affected and uh all
you can really do is is is protect your
own and pray for justice so let me ask
you question first right off the bat do
you think there's anything suspicious
about this main shooting and how have
you seen the media cover it all right
number two Gerald AC you know what
there's a cup that fell over I got to
fix it Gerald okay go ahead fine I'll
ask the question Gerald a how are you
doing I'm fine Stephen thank you for
asking I really appreciate that how are
you
doing no access to the Red Sea from
Egypt so listen I I this is not the only
thing I need to be admonished for Tim if
you can make sure that this is ready I
said desalinization and it's
desalination I asked you and you asked
me and you trusted me more importantly
and I led you astray and so I need to be
admonished for that also I don't need to
be admonished for the Red Sea Dead Sea
thing because everybody thought you said
Dead Sea
echoed you didn't say shark attack there
no there are no shark attacks in the
Dead Sea they' be dead dead sharks be
dead sharks dead sharks don't attack how
are you doing that was a Goosebumps
choose your own path
book dead sea sharks don't attack
terrorists I'm doing fine I'm actually I
feel great I didn't sleep and I think
I'm having that rebound effect of the
cortisol nice so I feel like I can take
on the world but I have a cramp in my
neck and when you hear this you know him
you love him brings a smile to our face
oh he's going to be actually uh Sunday
November 19
at the Bricktown comedy club in Tulsa
Oklahoma that's open now you can follow
him see his other dates uh on Instagram
at Josh firin how are you sir I am good
good no shark attacks no shark attacks
doing good yeah yeah did you know that
there's like five attacks something in
the Red Sea in the span of two weeks
people terorist as well yeah oceanic
white tips jacu still said they the most
dangerous sharks you guys can comment
below fact check me fact check me on
that I welcome it is that the Red Sea
cuz all the all the blood in the water
oh from the shark tax well I guess
that's
distasteful you better play your cards
right if you want to be in that that
third chair is a special place we don't
joke about shark attacks sorry yeah we
do we do okay a little bit we even have
stuff ready for everything today for the
Hamas conflict shooting like we're still
going to go in okay um they that's a new
so it's Tulsa they have a new club there
right yeah new club for uh the Bricktown
awesome chain it's a chain of clubs I do
chain I do chains I do Olive Garden next
week yeah you're the TGI Fridays of
comedians yeah well I'm doing it for
free cuz when you're there your family
yes
exactly actually Olive Garden is where
Jesus performed his last miracle is it
really The NeverEnding bread
bowl that's all we needed Lord we get it
but this is crap uh Bott I'll
pass bottomless shrimp at the Olive
Garden in Utah so yeah yeah how good the
shrimp yeah all right uh here really
quickly before we move on this is just
something to clear the pallet cleanse
the pallet sorry uh there's a tick
tocker right here now I get it you have
people you have the Zoomers at war with
the Boomers and the Boomers at war with
the Zoomers and then you have Generation
X like whatever and then you have
Millennials who've kind of been
forgotten but they they suck as well
this is when people talk about uh some
generations maybe being a little bit out
of touch and not having faced struggle
and I get it different Generations face
different struggles but not this person
uh here's a Tik tocker complaining about
what we all have known as work I know
I'm probably just being so dramatic and
annoying this is my first job like my
first 9 to5 job after college and I'm in
person and I'm commuting in the city and
it takes me forever to get there there's
no way I'm going to be able to afford
living in the city right now so that's
off the table like duh if I was able to
walk to work and it it'd be fine but I'm
not so it literally takes me like I
leave here like I get on the train at
7:30 and I don't get home until like
6:15 earliest and then like I don't have
time to do anything I don't I want to
shower eat my dinner and go to sleep I
don't have time or energy to cook by
dinner either like I don't have energy
to out like
that's the 9 to 5 schedule in general is
crazy being in the office 9 to 5 like if
it was remote you get off at 5: I don't
have energy how do you have friends like
how do you have time to like meet like a
guy I don't know like how do you have
time for like dating like I don't have
time for anything and I'm like so
stressed out and I'm also getting my
period so that's why I'm there it is you
could it's fine you buried the
lead so look going to have the guys
flocking to you can we put a moratorium
on the word crazy for things that aren't
crazy it's kind of like awesome they say
oh man this pasta is awesome it's Epic
no it's not it's not the wers of the
world are awesome you know if you see
that's awesome you me the state is a
inducing but also it's crazy 9 to5 is
crazy no you posting this is crazy you
know pissing down the elevator shaft and
claiming your Jesus which my neighbor
still does that's crazy working
standardized hours is not crazy and
here's something that people need to
hear I get it look a lot of younger
people and there's there's validity to
it you want more work life balance
that's it's the same reason by the way
that women are paid less than men in
general that 77 cents in the dollar it's
just average pay of men versus women why
because Women are Smarter in a lot of
ways in the way that they approach the
workforce they say well hold on a second
I don't want to be traveling non-stop
away from my family high-risk job or 94%
of workplace deaths are meant I don't
want to work in a Foundry I want to you
know watch a few toddlers for a few
hours be a public school teacher and
then go home and get three months off
and so you make a little bit less
because there is balance but here's the
thing if you want work life
balance you don't get to make six
figures you want to make six figures you
want to become rich you want guess what
you don't you don't have as many friends
you don't have as much time for friends
it's true you get home you shower you
recover and you get back to work and you
know what you want to do if you I don't
have time for the gym people here we're
in near 500 am. you just have to find a
way to fit what are your priorities is
your priority to go out and to hang out
with friends at night or do you want to
hit the gym in the morning 9 to5 is
crazy I can't live in the city all right
do you want to get to the point where
you can live in the city if that's your
priority then guess what put in some
more hours people think that 9 to5 is
insane and we've moved beyond that well
guess what the people who add value to
their company have not for crying out
loud think about this do you think any
of these folks would want to trade
people were working 8 to six with the
30in lunch break where they would do it
18 stories high on a beam with a lunch
PA people are still doing it by the way
yeah there are some people do when I was
a carpenter it was 10- hour day was
normal yeah perk you get to cat call the
ladies wait till she finds out about
graveyard shift blow her mind I can't
even there's still graveyards like we
just those people are dead why don't why
don't we just why do we have to put them
why do we call it a graveyard just throw
in the trash yeah I love how she acts
like an hour and a half which is not
short is like the worst thing ever like
most people's commute I we can pull a
stat on this what the average commute is
for somebody in a big city it's around
an hour or so I think like that is not
completely out of the norm I was like H
7:30 must be nice who said that Tim must
wait for kids oh yeah do you understand
like it's because you're selfish and
look I get it you've never had to do any
of these things for yourself before and
now you're getting hit in the face with
the real world and it's not College
where you can just sleep in and go party
with your friends got it but this is
life yeah used to it and start making
adjustments don't stay up as late if you
want to work out get up early and go out
instead if you want to meet some friends
meet in in the city after work then go
home like what's the problem here go
work a job get your money or or or move
somewhere that's not the big city right
where you can have a better work life
balance and you have a 10-minute drive
you don't have to live in New York City
I'm assuming that's what she's saying
when they say the city some City I have
New York City there's other which is a
silly place it's just life is choices
life is choices and when people say the
American dream is is dead I go let's go
through your choices what is it that
matters to you now we do face some
different obstacles that's not lost on
me I understand it the idea of job
permanent sure but the job permanence
that existed it only existed with the
kind of jobs that these people would
never want to work my dad was able to
okay you think he was going to
about 9 to5 it was assumed that was a
jumping off point let alone if he wanted
to move up right it's just about choices
by the way if at some point today
because we'll be talking about Hamas we
will be talking about the shooting going
on in Maine and these are always
sensitive subjects if you're watching on
YouTube and you see
this just head on over to rumble because
there's no reason to be watching on
YouTube anymore what are you doing with
your shirt Josh he's not there was a
there was a beard hair that fell on you
looked like you were tweaking Yourself
by the way New York
City short and curly is that girl
working 9 to5 oh my God Uptown Girl yeah
baby okay do us a favor and just make
sure you're not on camera when you do
that no it was a beard haired fell out
of my was in New York City they have the
longest average commute 80 minutes yeah
she's got a 90 minute commute so she's
10 minutes above average and she's
complaining on Tik Tok well hey look if
you don't want that you want a lower
cost of living what like I'm going to
live in pipy just fine just just I can't
help you just can someone disable I'm
not for censorship someone disabled her
social media so we don't have to listen
to it all
right so she's 10 minutes she's 10
minutes over average I'm 10 minutes
under I just I can't
look sorry no look we don't when people
say you don't we don't she now knows
exactly what it's like she can relate to
the people of Gaza all
right in main horrible event uh that
took place but it's equally horrible
that of course you have people on the
left and you have the David Hogs of the
world and um whatever moms against
whatever it is today uh politicizing it
before the bodies even uh really assume
room temperature and and to be clear uh
I used to have a policy where we didn't
want to discuss it until all of the
information we we don't have that luxury
anymore and we certainly don't have the
luxury of not correcting the
misinformation as it comes in so last
night lewi M man uh did he went on a
shooting spree you've probably heard
this killed at least 15 people as of uh
the time of this broadcast injuring what
seems to be dozens more here's a clip at
approximately 656 this evening uh a
couple of shooting incidents occurred
here with multiple casualties in the
city of Leon and police are currently
searching for a Robert R card 44 of 1983
of Bowden card is considered armed and
dangerous he is a person of interest
however and that's what we'll label him
at moving forward until that changes if
people see him they should not approach
card or make contact with him in any way
uh the shelter and place order that
currently stands in Lewiston remains a
vehicle which was a vehicle of interest
in this incident was located in Lisbon
and are now also asking residents in
Lisbon to shelter in
place okay they always have to do the
same thing like don't approach him
really I thought I was going to ask him
to be a pen pal hey are you that guy
yeah are you that guy oh I this is going
to be great for the Graham but can I get
an autograph here's the good look there
there's a silver lining because I get
this is a dark day for a lot of people
one of the Silver Linings is um the best
looking police officer ever is taking
this matter seriously he was on CNN
today I'm going why I mean this guy it's
like Billy Zayn walked out or Telly
savales and he's just squinting here you
go it was it's been a long stretch how
are the offic
doing take him out with those baby blues
the shooter's screwed he has Cojack
after
him looks better than Co you Mass
Shooters today have no
class you have no
decorum who hates you baby now jeez uh
the situation is it's still look it's
developing but I'm glad that that cap is
on the case yeah uh it hasn't stopped
those on the left from immediately
attributing motive and pushing gun
control now we don't know the motive
exactly but we have some good ideas
we'll get into that so right off the bat
Gavin Newsome straight out of Central
Casting yep couch said Republicans in
Maine rejected a bill this year that
would have required a waiting period for
firearm purchases they seriously could
not fathom waiting 72 hours to buy a gun
first off let me stop you there yeah
what if you're a woman with a
restraining order a man who says I'm
coming for you that happened in New
Jersey remember that someone had to but
they had to you go through this waiting
period for a firearm got killed got
killed by an ex-lover hey do you know
why people can't fathom a 72-hour
waiting period for a gun because they
have a constitutional right to not have
to wait 72 hours from purchasing a gun
sorry you guys may not like to say it's
in bad taste because the shooting just
happened I don't give a it's a
constitutional right yeah by the way uh
wouldn't have changed anything with this
Gavin I know you're leading with this
because you think that that makes you
sound reasonable and that everybody's
going to be on your side but when you do
that your izing this situation because
this guy was a Firearms instructor he
wasn't waiting 72 hours to go get the
gun he didn't just go buy the gun at a
Walmart and then go shoot it up he had
it at his house and by the way the only
photograph that we have him with a gun
is not a pistol which is what you were
talking about right there you're an
pardon my language but
I'm being a little direct because you're
trying to do what you always do anyway
there's more to this he went on to say
main also does not ban assault weapons
Define assault weapon require permits to
carry a gun in public what do you mean
open carry you know what you know where
else they don't uh Vermont Vermont
unless they've changed it Vermont has
the loosest gun laws in the country why
because they have a lot of hunters so
they're carrying their guns around they
shouldn't be arrested when cops can
abuse their Authority what happened to
what happened to defund the
police what happened hey how about
rather than defund the police remove
power from their hands where they can
simply site you for something that is a
constitutional right he said they don't
they don't require background checks on
all gun sales horeshit pardon my
language today this is again not for
children that is horeshit that's why we
did the campaign gift a gun we we took
two girls from going change my mind to
the gun range said hey let's purchase a
firearm they go oh my God I can't
believe all this paperwork anyone who
has ever purchased a firearm legally not
talking about a Saturday night special
out of the back of a van knows that
there is a background check and you can
just lie on it like Hunter Biden did
then you have uh Gavin saying we need to
amend the Constitution to prevent
tragedies like this there you go boom
amend the Constitution he said the quiet
part out loud Brooklyn dad everyone's
least favorite dad everyone's least
favorite person from Brooklyn is he
really a dad says in Maine it's harder
to get some cold medicines than it is to
get an AR-15 thanks to weak ass Senators
like Susan Collins she should have never
been reelected okay a couple of things
it's also harder to get cold medicine uh
in Italy than it is to get anything I
don't know if you know this but you live
in the United States just had a friend
friend of ours who was in Italy couldn't
couldn't get DayQuil seriously yeah and
and the reason that it's harder to get
some cold medicines by the way no one
has a problem getting diap it's if it
has like a fedrin or like Bron a right
or what's the other one Prima tetine
there are some that are stimulants that
are actually banned in sport so they
pick some extreme example and try and
create a parallel to an AR-15 but just
remember Gavin Newsome said we need to
amend the Constitution that's the only
way to implement any of this
that they actually want David hog in a
now deleted tweet his PR firm probably
told him oh that's not a good look said
join me in registering to vote against
the Republicans who are enabling these
shooters dick enabling enabling by the
way I believe he he left that up for
only minutes and our team caught it so
great job team thank you team thank God
for time machine set the timer Tool Man
Tim for people out there who are
confused and saying what do we know okay
here's what we know right now suspect
yes they got it right the name is Robert
card he is a certified Firearms
instructor he was a member of the US
Army Reserves uh he recently threatened
to shoot up a National Guard facility
and he reported hearing voices in his
head uh allegedly he was committed to a
mental health facility for 2 weeks this
summer so what we also know is from
these shootings apparently he shot up at
first a bowling alley and then a bar Pub
SL poool Hall which you're noticing a
pattern here then he shot up a Walmart
Distribution Center which seems
surprising until we realized that said
Distribution Center primarily shipped
bowling balls and pool tables so this is
a guy who's a three
L hit like if you want to see the
scumbag get the death penalty all you
enabling Republicans can we do the
expedited death penalty immediately
somebody sees him trying to go shoot
something else and they do the American
thing and put this guy out of his misery
yeah yeah yeah I don't want to hear a
call for a ceasefire either I want to
just I want him dead yeah exactly I want
him dead on where's the calling for a
ceasefire right now it's the just
happens when no that goes on in Israel
this is worse than a Halloween movie
like a Michael Myers movie yeah it's
Terri well you know this happened uh
actually in Canada it wasn't as many
people dead but there was a guy in the
mar times he had a shotgun and he was
just walking through a neighborhood
shooting people went on for days but
they knew where he was they just
couldn't stop him cuz no one had a gun
that's crazy yeah shot yeah yeah send a
mounty let's go he on Horseback they
need to be you know water to get their
Salt
Lick Sho the horses I don't know I'm I
don't know a lot about the equestrian
culture I just know that they they like
salt lick yes I don't know what Salt
Lick is but it sounds just salt it's a
big thing of salt and the horses lick it
sounds like something in the Dead Sea
yes that J that Gerald couldn't identify
in a map like what's that is that a lake
no was giving jald was giv direction to
Moses that's why they were lost for 40
years
seriously isn't this just tired at this
point comment and by the way hit the
like button if you're watching because
it helps with the algorithm and people
out there they don't know what's
actually happening with this shooting
they're just going to get the propaganda
look Gavin Newsome said it the only way
to implement what it is that they want
is to amend the constit is to change the
Constitution don't don't say that don't
say that to get rid of the Second
Amendment when he says amend the
Constitution he doesn't mean like put a
little bull Point likey we going to have
get rid of the second amendment period
no guns by the way do you want to live
in Israel with no guns we' talked about
this this is what happens when you have
no guns people can go knocking from door
to door to door that are criminals that
get guns CU they always find a way they
tend not to obey the rules and we help
pay for guns to get in the hands of
citizens in Ukraine yep so just not here
yeah just not here just not here in the
United States hey by the way before we
move on to anything else uh there's a
new speaker of the house really
that's about the energy I expected in
the room Mike Johnson Mike Johnson from
Louisiana and it was announced yesterday
and with the official announcement no
one was actually uh more surprised than
Mike
Johnson Mr representative Mr Johns wake
up huh you're the new Speaker of the
House
sir yeah
okay
yeah it's about all we have on that I
will tell
I'll tell you I was like a guy who
nobody really knows that's probably a
compromise nobody's happy with but then
Bill Crystal lost his mind on Twitter
like this guy didn't give enough money
to Ukraine so I like him now
okay Billy Crystal no no no the Lesser
Crystal Bill and it spelled it Mr
Saturday night he does a great Sammy
Davis yeah the former Republican bill
Crystal yeah former Republican bill
Crystal he's like Anna Navaro I used to
be a republican that gives me card card
to say all the
I love how you mispronounce the
swear word hey you know what if I have
nothing else for you guys nothing else
if I offer nothing else and there's a
very strong possibility um you can go
back to 2008 and see the ABCs of me
there was no money to
grift all right let's go to the truth
here about um the the Gaza water
shortage now the reason this matters is
because worse than misinformation
sometimes is um a a I guess you should
say subversion of half information
because then it grows and it grows and
it grows and people forget the context
uh originally that they were sort of fed
they were force-fed and then they start
believing New Lies so that's where we
are today with the idea of the Gaza
water shortage this is something that
comes up every few years where they talk
about the Palestinians not being able to
have access to water and they blame it
on Israel look wherever you line up in
this conflict truth matters it couldn't
be further from the truth that Israel
has just shut off the water supply to
Gaza or you can talk about the West Bank
wherever in Palestine at that given
moment in time and we're going to
transition into why none of these other
countries actually want Palestinians
they don't nobody wants them very clear
about that they're like the El
salvadorians of that area Now
worse I don't know I just know that most
people from South America have Bolivian
friends Ecuadorian friends are and
they're all like well we all you know
everybody hates Salvador and I get it
okay we go the point is
[Laughter]
let me ask you what have you heard about
the water situation in Palestine okay in
Gaza what is it that you believe all the
references will be made available at
louderwithcrowder.com you can click the
link in the description so the media
they do their best of course to try and
morally equate Hamas Israel okay Marley
was dead to begin with um and they
really like to point to one thing
recently and that is the water oh my the
water the UN says Water Production from
Municipal groundwater sources in Gaza is
less than 5% of what it was before the
war stop spilling it on the ground phip
lazarini head of the UN Agency for
Palestinians has warned Gaza is running
out of water and Gaza is running out of
life but it's not just turning off the
tap Israel has also blocked fuel which
is desperately needed to restart pumping
and treatment plants okay first off
Sesame Street had the you never let the
water run run he's just letting it run
down a nestly bottle I know it's like
half of it's going in what are you doing
you would be fired if you did that in
this office consistently because we have
that reverse osmosis filter in the REM
it's a whole thing it's great water that
we have in this office but but you don't
just let that's Liquid Gold don't let it
run on the ground yeah I cease to care
when you do
that they don't respect their own stuff
it's why all their old crap looks just
like their new crap now it's not just
Gaza for years you've heard the same
thing about the West Bank too right
let's let's kind of slap you in the face
with some truth the reason Gaza the West
Bank lack water is not because of Israel
but again because of the Palestinians
own governance right now of course that
is Hamas in the future it'll be some
other iteration of uh terrorist
but we'll go with Hamas right now if you
believe that it's because of Israel or
because of the big state in the United
States you are incorrect the defense is
wrong let's go through some claims here
and disabuse you of them here's the
claim that they make the water shortage
in Gaza is of course there could be no
other reason due to Jew cruelty
civilians there in Gaza are struggling
to access clean water and clean food as
this war rages on say it's resumed some
uh water supply to parts of Southern
Gaza but it's unclear if that water is
even safe to drink and consume why is
that unclear it was fine to consume a
couple of weeks ago and by the way why
do you think they're putting water on in
southern Gaza they told people to get
the hell out of Northern Gaza so they
could bomb Hamas well hold on we're
going to get into that because right now
we're talking about water all right you
know I don't want to but the Water Works
no but the point is like is it not safe
to I mean it doesn't take Columbo it's
like well was safe to consume last week
it's not okay yeah did you take a dump
in it they're pouring that water into a
mop bucket I know yeah I don't know what
the point of that news using that so
here's the truth before we get to before
we get to the rest before we get to the
cleanliness of the water which is a big
issue most water in Gaza is not from is
it's from Gaza only 13% of gaza's water
comes from Israel okay the remaining 87%
it comes from water supplies that are
basically they they stem from domestic
sources so 80% of it all these
references are available lorth cr.com uh
groundwater from the coastal
aquifer 97% of it is undrinkable though
uh because these guys they also engage
in over pumping they have all kinds of
problems with Wastewater agricultural
runoff uh 7% of the water is supposed to
come from desalin uh desalination plants
job right and just to be clear they have
built these salination plant entirely
from outside funding for the longest
time they refuse to so they don't even
have to pay for this by the way they
don't have to pay for these Wells they
don't have to pay for these desalination
plants these come from International
governments and we'll get to that the
newest plant that they have can provide
clean water up to about 17 uh sorry 175
what thousand met is it metric leaders
no no no this is people 175,000 people
okay then later we go into like what
cubic liters again we're going through
metric versus the I don't know why the
United States is the only place we don't
use metric because a foot is the king's
foot yeah and then they use 12 foot then
they use centimeters but we still use
it's silly yeah all
right now let's go through how they've
paid for a lot of these water
capabilities okay because a lot of
people argue well they don't have the
money because they're oppressed all
right they've received hundreds of
millions of dollars to improve
infrastructure in 2020 $117 million from
the World Bank 2021 $9 million from the
EU 2022 $100 million from used here's
another problem they face 50% % of water
and uh sewage their their infrastructure
in Gaza City it it it needed
Rehabilitation it needed new
infrastructure it needed a a facelift
before the war right so a lot of that
water that they actually get leaks out
of those pipes into ground leak out and
you just saw the hundreds of millions of
dollars that have been given to them to
improve their infrastructure over the
course of years instead they used the
water pipes to build Rockets because
those Rockets aren't just going to build
themselves
[Music]
can Brussels get a refund they should
be Hamas has an interesting PR team by
the
[Music]
way
[Applause]
this is why you can't drink water yeah
exactly abib is spray painting them and
this so they've been receiving hundreds
of millions of dollars from the
International Community the
International Community helped build
desalination plants helped them create
drill right for Wells helped get them
pipes and then they use the pipes for
rockets and by the unfortunately with
all this children are the ones who are
most affected Papa I'm so thirsty shut
up a I'm so sick of your whining keep
the pipe with white phosphorus or you
won't get your sodium nitrate but don't
we need these pipes for water too oh I
forgot aiz is so smart I just I just
meant that we we everyone everyone we
must all listen to Riz he is a
genius I I just thought we could use
them for water too must be nice to be so
smart you have to be conditioned to be
as stupid as Hamas is just to be clear
to be as stupid and evil as as Hamas
let's go through another
claim so right now they say well yeah
okay so we screwed up before the war and
sure you know pipes water pipes Rockets
tomato
tomato now we find ourselves at a
juncture where there isn't enough fuel
in Gaza to operate the water system so
that's the new complaint the cut off of
the clean water that used to come in
from Israel and the fuel needed to power
generators and the electricity needed to
power generators means that also sewage
cannot properly be treated um it's the
the the wastewater treatment plants are
shut down did she stick a Niel in a
light soet there are significant
concerns about a humanitarian crisis
based on an epidemic of disease in
addition to the the more than 4,000
people who've been killed as the since
the Israeli air strikes began thank you
baba du
now the
truth is that Hamas is hoarding massive
amounts of fuel okay now we have
photographs from the IDF and I know that
some of you will say Jews okay but first
we'll get some more evidence they have
photographs showing that Hamas is
hoarding at least
500,000 lers of fuel that's a lot okay
IDF spokesperson Jonathan uh I think
it's conus is how it's pronounced he
said that Hamas could Supply fuel to and
there are other examples not just from
the IDF just to be clear but here is him
saying that Hamas could Supply fuel to
power their water infrastructure
specifically you can see that Hamas has
between
850,000 and 1 Mill ion lers of fuel
depending on their priorities they can
of course send this fuel to hospitals
and to pump water using generators or
they can continue using it for fighting
against Israel okay now and that's a
tough that's the Catch 22 it's like
hydration uhuh kill Jews I get it it's a
real Sophie's terrorist
choice now those are IDF claims and
you'll say I don't trust the Jews oh
fine I don't trust anyone who's Jewish
if they have too many vowels in their
last name my trust goes down we see that
direct correlation from Pew research I
think but we have a long track record
with Hamas right in October 15th Hamas
uh was alleged to have stolen fuel from
the UN right this says the UN received
reports yesterday that a group of people
with trucks reporting to be from the
Ministry of Health the deao authorities
of Gaza removed fuel medical equipment
from the agency's compound in Gaza you
can go back to uh when you had the
fatila Fiasco you can go back uh in time
you just rewind 3 years or 5 years at
any given moment in time Hamas has been
known to hoard fuel to hoard resources
and to use their people as human Shields
so right now you'll say it's only
confirmed by the IDF we don't have it
confirmed by the international
intelligence Community but we have no
reason to believe that it is a lie so we
know that it is not because Israel has
shut off their water and it is not
because they have had their fuel shut
off by someone else also there's not not
to mention the little fact that let's
take a little bit of personal
responsibility Hamas okay you're at War
you killed ACH bunch of innocent people
it's not their job to give you both
water and fuel you're like the bitching
Tick Tock Zoomer of the terrorist
World especially when the last couple of
years you've gotten over $200 million to
solve the problem wouldn't you if you're
Hamas and you're about to attack the
Jews who give you water wouldn't you did
like the first thing you do it's like
all right we got to be independent of
these guys cuz we're about to kill a lot
of them for no particular reason at all
then we hate their civilians why don't
we make sure we have water right they
plays right into their hand man it plays
into their their plan well they did it
on purpose that's the whole point you
can compare again what is Israel they
okay the first thing we have to whether
you like the way they do it or not we
have to make sure that our people have
water we have to make sure that we're
able to have proper irrigation that we
can farm that we are self- sustaining
they first go how do we protect our
people now you may say that it's an
ethnos State and that's an argument that
we can have and I think you're wrong but
at the very least they actually want to
preserve the livelihood of their people
Hamas has no interest in that the last
they build Rockets first they build
bombs first they kill their people first
then afterwards they'll get some water
for crying out loud animals go to the
watering hole first if they think
there'll be a
drought and by the way this is one thing
before I move on because I want to get
to some historical context this talk
about water it has me parched not only
could I use a snack but I found
something out in the office the other
day can we bring can we bring in let's
bring in our our our our snack is right
girl thank you thank you can you show
that to the camera this is new this is
something and I would love for people to
comment you can leave that on on on the
desk is this new sweetheart I had never
heard of this before thank you
plumcots is that is that plums like a
cumquat it's a plum cot Plum cot plumot
it's a plum cot please comment below I
walk down to the office everyone
stop has anyone here heard of a plum cot
and no one had nope no wait one person
had one person one person we didn't
really trust Apple Jack yeah it was
Apple Jack it was Apple Jack he had
heard of The Plum cot do you know what a
plum cot is I a CAU full of plums sounds
disgusting is it a cross between a plum
and a cumquat that's what I imagine I
think it's
apricum and an apricot apricot Plum and
apricot these been rinsed probably not
can you you want you want one they sound
disgusting oh I know very I know it's
very girl-like throw just you see but
I'm going to hit something in the studio
you look like Durant did I yes that's
what I think I look just like Durant do
you want one no cuz you'll have to throw
it farther actually yes because you'll
have to throw it farther he going to
throw the
him and his Notre D reflexes what is it
what is pretty good what is it oh look I
pull one out and it's
bruised I don't know what it tastes like
tastes more like but you want me to Wing
one at you no I don't want you to Wing
one at me it's not as t as tree and
Wizard of Oz is sorry guys I know this
probably doesn't matter to you let me
have this one I was very confused
brought to you by big Plum
clout are they good good that's
good but now I didn't realize I don't
think I've ever just had an a OT
straight only time I've eaten apricot is
when I accidentally was washing my face
and it went in my mouth St IES St Ives
St
IES can't use that though the they found
out the apricot shells cause it causes
microabrasions and it's actually bad for
you oh microaggressions no thanks no
microabrasions micro
abrasions is that what I changed my mind
during the transition seriously though
comment below I didn't know anything
about I forgot the word plum Plum cots
Plum never heard of them all
[Music]
right actually the problem now it's good
I don't want to do the show I just want
to be eating the moon well you have to
though I find it interesting that um the
only reason that we're hearing about G's
water problem that they've had for a
couple years now it seems forever for
water problems in the Middle East for a
few days now uh we only time we have
find out about it is when uh Israel bad
guy is uh bombing them yeah when they
respond yeah yeah yeah when they respond
yeah when they were attacked yeah it's
just just so thank you Israel for
bringing light to the uh water shortage
in Gaza we appreciate the world
appreciates it yeah maybe Palestinians
appreciate it thank you very much maybe
Ashton Kutcher will go over there and
he'll uh he'll set up some Nets he won't
bring Mia won't bring mil dummy you
remember that someone bring that up from
Mission Control they had that I think
the charity was nothing but net uhhuh
but net that's the problem though it
shouldn't be nothing but net you should
also use chemicals no no that'll hurt
the bird's eggs but what do they do for
the other hours of the day when they're
not in their bed that's assuming they
have a bed
okay let's here's another claim that you
will hear it's not just Gaza you know
Israel's been restricting water to all
to to to to like the West the West Bank
you hear about usually you hear about
Gaza and then you hear the West Bank and
sometimes people even confuse them
because they're used so often us far as
like professional victimhood they've
been restricting water to the West Bank
forever director General Adel Yen says
there's plenty of water in the West Bank
to meet the needs of
Palestinians Israel controls 85% of its
resources that including cars
distribution qu and location of Wells he
says the last time a construction of a
new working well was approved was 15
years ago okay here's the truth the West
Bank has plenty of access to water
something called the oso 2 Accords yeah
okay usually if you read it if you look
it up you have to spell like write it
Roman numeral 2 like a rocky phone
that's true this is 1995 okay these
Accords uh determined that the West Bank
would need about 70 to 80 million cubic
met of water per year okay and then
these Accords were involved in saying
okay how where you can drill uh how
we're going to sort of partition this
2022 the amount pumped from Palestinian
wells in the West Bank was 108 million
cubic met which is more which is more
than 70 to 80 million cubic meters again
all of this is available we make the
references available but here's the
problem this water is not always very
consistent they have those capabilities
but Palestinians and the representatives
in the West Bank uh they won't repair
the Leaky pipes they won't use treated
Wastewater to irrigate their Farms they
use inefficient irrigation methods they
plant the wrong crops at the wrong time
and by the way not to mention with all
this they still steal water from Israeli
water pipes that's something no one
talks about it's like siphoning gas they
do that like no no this is the good Jew
water
gosh it's blessed it's and and just like
Gaz of the West Bank they receive
massive amounts of outside funding for
said Water Systems 2023 World Bank alone
$73 million we're talking about the West
Bank now 2023 as well you said $14
million you're close to100 million and
they still can't get their crap together
also the Palestinian Authority people
say it's not all the Palestinian
Authority okay they're also they've been
caught red-handed consistently stealing
Aid you send them money for humanitarian
Aid and it goes to terrorists they have
the it's like public schools here in the
states only end up with a failed test
score you send humanitarian Aid to any
governing body in Palestine and it gets
it gets used for terrorism they have the
money they have the locations they have
the ability and they have the green
light to be self- sustaining they refuse
to because they just really really
really want to kill people I wish that I
loved anything as much as Palestinian
authorities loved killing Jews oh my
gosh I at what point do we not care
anymore at what point do we say look
you've had first off in the Palestinian
thing on the West Bank they have more
water than they need when they're like
and they haven't drilled well in 15
years that's because they have a surplus
they just don't know how to they have
those capabilities that's the thing
that's a little bit great they may not
have that water right now they have
access to it but they don't they're
constantly they'd rather they'd
rather squabble over ter say yeah but I
want that water like but that water's
for the Jews you can get it here like
yeah but we we're saying that that's our
land okay but right now you have no
water well fine then none of my people
get water okay you're killing them yeah
it's like a it's like a toddler yes it's
like a toddler or a dog
terrorist di like a dog it is and this
is what you every single time former
Vice President Joe Biden or anybody else
in the world comes on and says we're
going to give money to the Palestinians
to help out in Gaza to help out in the
West Bank this is what happens hundreds
of millions of dollars go in and they
still have leaky pipes this is not a
major problem to fix and if it is we've
already given you the money to fix it
I'm sorry that you didn't do your
homework properly and you built Rockets
to fire into Israel but that's on you
people don't get water yes also by the
way without proper irrigation you can't
have these
Plum plums PL Plum I say they're good
though I'm not even joking they're
pretty good I like it I thought
considering how hard it was like you
know you get a plum that's hard it's too
tart and bitter this is firm with a
crunch but it's still largely sweet oh
yeah nice and firm and hard and um sweet
and juicy as well said can I just say
something thank you to today's sponsor
Monsanto yeah you're not a sponsor
that's what I wanted to
say this is not a sponsor thank you
Norman borlo now
dwarf wheat is it borlock I don't
remember Norman borlock Norman borlock
guy who saved more lives than anyone in
the human in the history of humanity of
the world allegedly okay so all this
brings us to the water stuff that you
now know is a lie this also is a big
reason why no one wants to bring in the
Palestinians we're going through a
little bit of geohistory here today
people say the Jews don't want to take
in Palestinians well okay true as that
may be neither do all the people who
claim that they want to support the
Palestinian people this has been going
on for a very very long time that's why
historically they said to the Jews all
right you were being gassed in record
numbers you're saying never again here's
an area that was historically yours
we'll set up a small area for you to
live there because kind of no one lives
there and no one really wants to deal
with these people so let's go through
the list of people who are not Israel
who don't want to take in the
Palestinians you've heard ad nauseum
calls from these progressives to take in
refugees from Palestine here's Jamal
Bowman saying 50% of the population in
Gaza are children the International
Community as well as the United States
should be prepared to welcome refugees
from Palestine while being very careful
to vet and not allow members of Hamas
kind of hard to do considering that a
majority of Palestinians still have a
favorable view of Hamas now we don't
know how accurate those polls are
because they're probably run by uh Hamas
research you know Quin Quinnipiac it's
like rasmia Hamas but House Productions
yes exactly uh here's AOC making this
same speaking the same kind of jibber
jabber should Arab countries be taking
on The Lion Share of the burden to
absorb what could be over a million if
not more refugees from Gaza I think
there's something to be said about the
Region's Partners being able to support
and step up Palestinians however that
does not abdicate the United States from
our historic role that we've played in
the world of accepting refugees and
allowing people to restart their lives
here I'm not going to lie I wasn't I've
already watched the clip I wasn't really
paying I was like these are surprisingly
good yeah I heard uh people are
surprised here I'm like I want a plum
yeah exactly she could eat this thing in
one bite by the way she can also stick
her whole fist in her mouth I've seen it
don't give her any peanut butter though
these these are the same people before
we get into all of these nations who
don't want to take in the
Palestinians you talk about the they
call for a ceasefire after people were
raped and murdered just to be clear that
is supporting
terrorism
please see Daddy
smile come on bring your feathery ass
here
[Music]
come you ate my
bird hey ceasefire guys ceasefire like
we need to calm it down down this is way
too violent See
Fire way too violent I love how he
focused on the bird in that at that
point in the movie he'd already eaten
several people as well I just realized I
forgot where the where the the Stinger
was supposed to be in here I don't think
we have them in the uh in the but it
doesn't matter I think we know what
we're doing all right they're in there
they're in there are they yeah they're a
little F later oh okay all right you're
doing great all right
shut
and Yakuza
fired yay time to
close you have that on your sound bites
like a trump going your fire okay so
let's go into
uh who do we have we're going to go
through Jordan Egypt Syria Lebanon I
don't know we have a bunch of countries
egpt Qatar Iran Saudi
[Laughter]
Arabia that would trying to make me seem
crazy where people they're going to have
expect me to be dancing with with knives
after the
show with running mascara and then Nick
going be like I swear to God he's
dead he's convinced Britney Spears is
dead yes he is I think he's right I'm on
board that's when he mentioned that I
was like I know he's not a conspiracy
theorist but he is he is sure that
should tell you something all right so
Arab countries in the Middle East don't
want to take in refugees just to be
clear it's it's a bad idea they know it
this week um you have this uh refuges
queen reia of Jordan not to be with
Queen of the Damned Aaliyah who um by
the way overloaded her plane with 1,000
lb of
luggage of luggage that's why the pl
tragedy but the pilot was like this we
are all going to die she's like I don't
give I want my luggage and he was like
whatever she bringing two of each animal
or something yeah exactly every the I
get there's more to it than that but the
point is just if you're flying private
respect the envelope okay so Queen Ria
of Jordan she actually tried her dness
to explain why her country would not
again queen of Jordan why they won't be
accepting you should we should but why
they won't be accepting Palestinian
refugees the people of Gaza now are are
facing two choices either they leave or
they face death or Collective punishment
so essentially they're giving a choice
between expulsion or extermination
between ethnic cleansing and genocide
and no people should be
given have to face that kind of choice
and what my husband was referring to is
the people of Palestine should not of
Gaza should not be forced to be moved
again they are most of the ref most of
the uh res cut that
stutter yeah she's she's really dancing
around her well the reason why is
because she's trying to run she's trying
to run interference do some damage
control for her husband the king in case
you were
wondering King Abdullah II again Roman
numeral who said this a part of the
question on the issues of refugees
coming to Jordan and I think I can quite
strongly speak on behalf of not only of
um um um Jordan as a nation but of our
friends in Egypt that is a red line uh
because I think that is the plan by
certain of The Usual Suspects to try and
create de facto issues on the ground no
refugees in Jordan no refugees in Egypt
all right I did not expect him to sound
that way when he spoke yeah like a
British pretty much let's just before we
get we'll go into all of these different
countries but uh let's really just a
let's just set the stage the reason that
none of these countries are taking in uh
Palestinians uh even though they all you
know uh don't like uh the Jews is
because they all hate
everything I hate everything about Jews
all
right was
that was that three three three three
doors down three down yeah no I think
that was Creed no it's third blind can
you higher can I have some
water I think it was Three Days Grace
Three Days Grace Three Days Grace
they're sitting in the palace right now
Three Days Grace Days Gra yeah was that
was that was oh Three Doors Down was
a call
Super which is a power line for Hamas
paraglider I think great isn't that
isn't that great that one's
Kryptonite
Kryptonite I say we need a hero to save
us we're not going to stand here and
wait Palestinians trying to leave
they're like I'm here without you
baby looking for a new country I withan
I can't go on not bombing
you I really want to see that
Palestinian Nelly it's all in my head I
want to kill Jews over and over
again because I've been called from
muhamed and it would hurt so bad
electricy heart I can't go on not B
juice you stay on my white man grass you
his song Live Like You Were Dying is
just how many ways he would kill the
Jews that's the Jihad Melody to live
like you are definitely
dying okay so let's go through country
by country cuz you only hear about
Israel Jordan as the wonderful and very
fetching Queen stated yes
uh dude she she is significantly younger
and prettier than he is yeah that's
definitely pretty man there goes a guy
with thing that did you see there goes a
guy with a plane yeah the king a country
he has a country he's like it's good to
be king okay we get it he doesn't sound
like that though no he doesn't it's it's
good to be king I think it's good to be
king of Jordan yep I'm the king of
Jordan this is our Arab land there's a
it be played by Jason
St I'm the king of Jordan
here they'll just come in and they like
tell you is a deal it's what we're going
to
do we're not going to let these
Palestinians
in pretty good I just wanted to be a
simple diver I'm the transporter I don't
transport Palestinians
though they stay
a great St who does Jason St all right
love
it so who would want to
Jordan as the there lot of ladies that
want to do I bet the queen of Jordan
wants to do Jason St them I don't blame
that's why she's like hey can you get a
British accent for me Jason Sten really
does it like that like that good-looking
cop looks like Cojack that would be
great have Jason Statham play the new
cojak if they brought it back bring it
back up bring back up the best looking
cop ever
come on now that does look like comedian
Wyatt Co he's probably running for
congress yeah he probably is it's like
Billy Zayn bald he does yeah he does
it's like the Phantom all right okay
sorry let's go through the countries so
Jordan King Abdullah does not feel that
the Palestinians should be displaced is
what he says he's like he goes hey hey I
don't think that uh they should be you
know the whole thing is they shouldn't
be displaced but then tool menu can be
ready here the real reason is actually
because they hate them
I hate everything about Jews no you hit
the wrong Stinger that was the one about
the Jewish one Lebanon this is Jordan
sorry this isord that that was the one
for Jordan well the one for Jordan go go
well no that that is the one that was it
well just use the
whatever the real reason is they hate
them okay 1951 in case you guys don't
know this history with Jordan uh the
pales there was a palestini assassinated
the King of Jordan on on on Temple mount
the great grandfather of the current
King so he probably still has a sore
spot about that he's like you know I
don't want them to be displaced and like
Yeah question is it because um he killed
your great
great-grandfather
no well well if maybe if they well I can
separate business from personal right so
it doesn't bother you
yeah what about I know you were just
getting over it but 19 years later when
they tried that's right 19 Palestinians
they tried to assassinate the King of
Jordan the father of the current King
like hey did that bother you it's a
displacement thing they killed your they
killed your great-grandfather they tried
to kill your dad we let the buy guns be
by guns oh so let him in
no so he survived the assassination in
Jordan and then uh there was uh this uh
resulting war and you know what happened
yeah Palestinian war from Jordan there
was a whole thing who
won no one wins oh yeah no one wins I
mean have you been to Jordan or
Palestine it' be tough to be like w you
guys really got the Lion Share allaha
wins the desert wins now let's go to
Egypt all right hey Egypt okay Egypt
they're right there you got Israel you
got Egypt they could take them in
they're trying to claim that well
actually the economy is not able to cope
with the influx of
refugees um you know so we're not going
but then the US said hey hey it's okay
we'll help we'll pay for refugees and
they're like no no no no no no no that's
okay and the said no no we can really
help because the real reason with Egypt
is as it relates to Palestinians they
hate them I hate you hate so as it
relates to Egypt Hamas is an offshoot of
the Muslim Brotherhood uh you know which
is a terrorist organization um they
helped win the Egyptian election in 2012
before they were immediately overthrown
by the Egyptian Army in 2013 so fast
and and here's the thing you live in the
states and so you're easily fooled by
prop you don't understand what a coup is
actually like no if you think January do
you have any idea how often leaders get
taken out get swapped out by an army and
then gorillas like do you do you know
the history of
Haiti they come in and they're like yeah
it's a really cute thing you guys had an
election no this happens everywhere
except for where you are so you can go
on Tik Tok and about having to
work from 9: till 5: and having a 35
minute commute here's how one Egyptian
who again you would think hey Egypt
they're going to help their people the
Palestinians these are not their people
here's how one Egyptian uh expressed
Egypt's sentiment towards Palestinians
in Gaza he said you keep guard dogs on a
leash in your yard not in your bedroom
because they should threaten your
enemies not your children wow that's
what he said so he's saying we should
use the Palestinian people as guard dogs
in other words we should use them
against the Jews but we don't want them
in the house with the children he used
the guard dog analogy by the way we have
exclusive video of said Representatives
runin um with some Palestinians while
kite surfing in the Red
[Music]
Sea I get that you have some trauma you
have to peel back but hey hashtag notall
Palestinians Red Sea more like Dead Sea
now right come on thing is that's an
actual C though and he won't know I did
I'm being a total C right now I'm sorry
Gerald okay yeah it's okay don't worry I
still have the you're being a total dead
see you next Tuesday can't fire him he's
a day
raider a day raate fire a day raider
well I mean cuz you're not you know
you're not like a salary cuz you come in
you're on doing I thought you meant like
a like a pirate like a Raider like I'm a
like I raid your house dur the day I
thought that you thought I said day
Raper oh which is the worst kind of
Raper because it you know you need you
need the you need the cover of night
well I wasn't yeah if you if one were to
rape you would want the cover of night
clearly more risky no no it's it's less
risky with the cover of night the key is
cover yeah in the day in the day you
don't have the cover there's no cover
there's no night there's no cover yeah
in the daytime they're welcoming With
Arms Wide
Open just yeah no cover of
night what an awful side raped right
over all right
split like a
coconut out keep
going
help can you rip Me
Harder blink if you're in danger now I'm
blind and I can't see tickets are 39
cents Ser did tell that we were Fox uh
when I worked at Fox News and they were
guests on red eye no yeah they were
guests on rede they were announcing
their new tour and then like the day
after the tickets were they were like 78
cents no I know I felt so bad is that a
promo who's out there selling 78 Cent
tickets I mean it's when you you can't
sell fees at that point it's just like
it's more of a moral victory for cre I
guess like look we can't sell tickets
we're just going to Canvas it steal it
for
75 that's so sad okay so now we go to
Syria all right so we've gone through
Egypt right we've gone through Jordan
okay let's go to Syria hey certainly
they'll take in the Palestinians it's
only the Jews who won't well they kind
of say the same thing as Jordan they say
that the Palestinians should stay and
build their own State and not flee
that's what they say they're like well
we don't want to enable Israel we don't
want to enable Israel because it'll
Force these people you guys should you
guys should stay and fight but the real
reason that Syria doesn't want to take
them they hate them I hate you hate the
Palestinians are they Sunni Muslims and
of course with Syria they're anti Sunni
as it relates the sentiment in Syria's
government they're just they don't want
anything to do with it but they just say
hey you guys go you've got it you don't
need our help yeah you build a state
over there that's a nice plot of land
that's a nice come on you don't let them
no hey you know what you build you you
you take those pipes meant for water you
build rockets and that feeling of
accomplishment is something those Jews
can never take away from you that's
right don't let them push you around and
I would be doing every member of this
terrorist organization to disservice if
I didn't allow you you to build that
yourself that's right yeah they don't
want to take their recruits away no no
it's 50% children after all exactly 50%
children and I want you to feel as the
sense of
accomplishment you know you I can't
teach you self-esteem so you stay there
and you know and we'll stay over here
let's go to Lebanon something something
something head something going on okay
so they say that granting Palestinians
like pales knock knock it's like it's
like the little
piggies only only all of them have a
house of brick and Hamas can't huff and
puff and blow they just have to
stay out
there knock knock Hamas we're not here
are you here no I heard you say there's
no one there but that I heard someone
say it which means there's someone there
you're so
stupid I'm sorry I'm a child on cold
medicine so Lebanon has said that well
if we granted the Palestinian
citizenship it would upset this whole
like Bal this balance in our country
that's largely sectarian so you know I
just we don't think that it's great for
the health of uh current Lebanon the
real reason the Lebanese as it relates
to the Palestinians hate
them I hate you hate now with the
history doesn't get old here hope the
Palestinians kind of hung Lebanon out
Lebanon out to dry uh when they were
they struck Israel right during the
Lebanese Civil War this is between 1975
and 1990 and that led to Israel invading
Southern
Lebanon so you're so stupid
so like hey we've got an internal
conflict let's pick on that guy yeah
it's like coming home to this the
roommate who just trashes your apartment
leanon just he's like what what the what
the
well there was Jews I had to I had
to kill them I told you you can't put a
fork in the microwave but I I had to
it's like they don't think anything
through and this isn't just knew so
right now they say oh no we can't do it
right now but for a very long time the
Lebanese great food by the way have been
treating the Palestinians like dog
so most Palestinians I didn't know this
until this morning great find uh Ginger
Snap if they're born in Lebanon so
Palestinians born in Lebanon have been
denied citizenship the majority of them
they're legally barred from working in
professions like medicine law
engineering and you guys about the
United stat think about this for a
second you guys talk about the dreamer
act in the United States the majority of
Palestinians born in Lebanon are denied
citizenship completely you would think
hey Lebanon of course they're going to
so we have Egypt Syria Jordan Lebanon
let's go to clock boy favorite vacation
spot let's go to Qatar okay I've also
heard cutter I don't care that's fair
they've been it's not okay so people
correct me comment below is it cutter is
it qar this guy by the way thank you for
your service he's been overseas I would
assume he knows it's G it's uh oh that's
the same I I made that up it both
ways what finish the songd was was that
a slogan no I just by
Kar much funnier yes see there you go
how's your terrorist here
yes I'm your C I'm your Syria I have
diarrhea
that's not a good razor commercial at
all all right so qar I'm going with qar
they've actually been largely silent on
the Palestinian refugees uh that doesn't
change the fact that they have strict
laws you know regarding Refugee
settlements now the the reason are
resettling I should say at this point
and I don't really know if we would call
it resettling because I've never really
allowed them to settle there in the
first place they're like don't get don't
put your feet up don't get too
comfortable the real reason they've been
silent qar uh is because they too hate
them I hate you hate so as it relates to
Kar you know being an offshoot of the
Muslim Brotherhood uh Hamas is seen as
sharing in you know the Muslim
brotherhood's kind of anti- Monarch
Origins uh and uh those in Qatar they're
they're well here's the thing they're
scared of Palestinian terrorism the
reason that they're scared that they it
could result in terrorism is because
Qatar helps fund it yeah qar helps fund
Hamas and Palestinian terrorism AB
and we don't we don't terrorist where we
eat they know something they're on to it
they know they also host the leadership
of Hamas in some ways I know that the
the meetings that have been taking place
they like like we'll take like the very
finest of you but not the normal C we'll
take you for like a nice summer visit
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then you go
back special guest then you go back
right we'll give you money to blow up
Jews just you know keep it over there
they're like What About Bob they keep
coming look I've been working on
boundaries
okay boundaries I'll fund terrorism but
I won't have it here let's go to another
country everyone's favorite of
the world right now if God were to give
the world an enema he would stick it in
Iran so they haven't given an official
reason for not taking refugees but again
we can we'll make some inferences but
spoiler alert Iran hates the
Palestinians I hate you hate
that's why they sent him to die yes so
much hate anti- Hamas it's been growing
by the way among the Iranian public
despite uh this sort of regime's growing
support of Hamas there's a bit of a
disconnect there so October 20th here's
a tweet that shows a video of Iranians
booing uh a moment of silence for Gaza
before a soccer game uh do we have is a
clip or we just have the uh it's just
the Tweet just a tweet where it says
Iranian football fans booed during a
minute a minute silence for the people
of Gaza at the beginning of a Friday
match earlier this month fans were heard
chanting take that Palestinian flag and
shove it up your a uh you know star star
that's a long chant yeah it is yeah I to
get everybody on board with that that's
really hey hey ho ho take that
Palestinian flag and shove it up the
rest wait wait
what okay does not go at the previous
beat no it doesn't well in arabit
Probably sounds different almost like
you're out of out of cadence guys let's
get in sync here come on let's tighten
it up this is the yell rally I'm going
to need a little more from the left can
can we so hold on a second let me can
someone what have we gone through we've
gone through Lebanon Syria Jordan Egypt
Qatar am I missing anyone Iran we went
through Iran and now we have Saudi
Arabia so Saudi Arabia again you've only
heard about Israel not taking in
refugees uh they haven't really given
much uh much sort of nuance I know
that's a word that people like to use
when they're not super intelligent and
so they love to act as as though
everything is in a gray area because
they don't want to have to explain it or
face accountability so no real Nuance
from Saudi Arabia they just outright
hate
them I hate you hate yeah in Saudi
Arabia anyone showing any kind of
support for uh the Palestinian cause can
be imprisoned or or worse I I do respect
their honesty yes yeah at least they
just came out they go hey we're not
going to try to you guys we
don't like them we don't like those guys
come on I'm not a fan okay have you had
their food terrible they're all they're
all kids too like they no work at I have
got to say I am just not a Hamas
guy I tried I tried I'm not they've even
ban you've heard of the First Amendment
they've banned Saudi imams from praying
for the
Palestinians which how little faith in
your God must you have if if you think
you're in the right
and you walk to IM was like okay we pray
for stop stopen stop stop stop stop stop
stop hey hey can we 86 what the she
doesn't know what she's talking about
she's
crazy this Imam is
crazy they think it's like a noise meter
in
heaven if it gets loud enough he's a
falsy mom I don't know this guy and the
Saudi Arabians are more willing to deal
with Israel than the Palestinians and of
course you see this after the Abraham
Accords which by the way were the
largest sort of in peace agreements we
had seen in the Middle East In Our
Lifetime that was Biden or uh Obama or
you almost got me you almost got me but
seriously nobody pray nobody uh pray for
you know for Biden to win well because
I'm a Christian but I just don't want
God to get his wires
Dro pray hey you know what pray to pray
to your zoroastrian copycat God for
Hamas to take out little Satan and big
Satan and uh you know we'll still have
the world's most powerful military I'll
pray to uh God I'll pray to good guy God
God yeah Christ the judeo-christian God
and we'll let the cards fall where it's
so stupid Oh I can't I don't pray we
have to ban you from praying because I
just look I like God the man upstairs
but sometimes he has a lot on his
plate what like well he prayed for it
what am I supposed to do come on there's
like secret prayers going on yes come on
we're going to pray for the Palestinians
in here yeah they're using like
pseudonyms like and we pray for the
palatines I know what that
means the Philistines no nobody prays
for Philistines you're praying
for those that we shall not name yes so
now a big reason why Saudis they by the
way they uh they see normalizing
relations with Israel as push back
against the proxy wars from Iran in the
Middle East so this is not to say that
these people love the Jews just to be
clear uh this is just to say that uh the
Palestinians have never been respected
and have never been welcomed by any
surrounding country by any Islamic
Arabic these countries in the Middle
East and I get it not we're not going to
say all Arabic because people say Okay
Iranian Persian Assyrian I I get that
I'm just using this as an umbrella term
non-jew countries okay non-jew countries
they don't like the Palestinians because
they've all had problem they have been
nothing but problems for all of these
countries for a very long time and then
when these Wars come out some of them
decide hey we can uh use this for a
little bit of anti-Semitic propaganda
Saudi Arabia said you know what no we
would rather deal with Israel than deal
with Iran and the proxy wars in the
Middle East and by the way this has
inspired the Palestinian people to
produce a new reality show so they do
make lemon out of yeah keep for those on
audio it's way worse than you thought it
was what the god keeping up with the
Palestinians for those listening on
audio and by the way if you're on the
road and you do want to listen anywhere
you listen to podcast uh it's a good
idea actually if you go and just leave a
rating there you can listen to the audio
version Spotify Apple Android Google
Stitcher all those places we are
available there because sometimes people
say the bandwidth if they're watching on
Rumble when they're traveling uh can be
tough so don't let us lose contact with
you so if other Arab Nations Middle
Eastern nations are completely unwilling
to take in the Palestinian refugees we
went through Syria Jordan Egypt Lebanon
Qatar Saudi Arabia Iran am I missing any
don't say Dead Sea I swear I I will
murder you when your sleep
Egypt did I say Egypt thank
you if none of these places are first
off why should we take them why is it
our responsibility why is it the
responsibility of the nation at war with
them to take them furthermore do you
notice a pattern do you notice a pattern
there right if you know you meet someone
calls you a terrorist in the morning hey
maybe you met someone who's just an
islamophobe if for the entire day
everyone is unwelcoming to you because
of your terrorist activity you're the
terrorist yeah and by the way they have
access to their own water so all of that
let me know if there was anything here
that was new that you didn't know
comment below I know we had to go
through a little bit of a deep dive I
guess some people say what they call
them deep Dives we used to call them
meat segments the we use meat on theone
and none of this is possible by the way
without you joining and supporting at
lit.com mugclub you get this wonderful
hand etched mug it's $89 annually you
get Nick depalo Monday through Friday
sorry Monday through Thursday 5 p.m. you
get our Friday show you get 50% more
show every sorry 100% more show every
single day you get Alex Jones's show you
get Brian Kal show you get the hotwin
show we are building out a network you
support our undercover investigative
journalist unit uh and you know what
it's also what allows us to not be
beholden to Big Tech when when people
out there say the media is stopping this
information from getting out or the
media is throttling it's true and by the
way we have been harmed
irreparably uh for sure being
demonetized on YouTube um you know it
wasn't just being demonetized though I'm
sure that many of you wouldn't like to
have a business where you just lose $23
million in Revenue off the bat but the
real issue is we were gaining 150 to
200,000 subscribers every single month
demonetized gone down to 10,000
remonetized accidentally because of an
intern at Google it's a funny story back
up to 150,000 new subscribers a month
demonetized boom gone so it's the reach
we don't have the ability to reach more
people if not you uh and mug club and
you guys sharing it um and we really
really genuinely appreciate it nothing
happens without you look because I know
you won't do this I'm going to do this
so um well you you kind of called this a
little bit I said I'm the next pitch
ball right past the fly well good Lord
must
[Music]
have look you know you guys may have
heard over the last several months uh a
number of organizations out there saying
hey we're we're actually getting screwed
by big Tech and we're going to make some
changes so that we're not so dependent
on big Tech especially over the last
couple of days you've seen that happen
where people have said hey you know big
Tech I guess is out there we're going to
go to a subscription model and look
that's great I'm glad people are finally
coming on to join this team like we have
taken and you specifically for years
have taken the hit for blazing the trail
we have been punched in the mouth over
and over and over again by big Tech and
we've said hey hey hey guys the best Way
Forward for this movement if we want to
be able to reach people and make this
work we have to get out of bed with big
Tech we have to do it and people always
told us they knew better than us people
always told us that that wasn't
necessarily the way to go or people
always told us that they had a better
way they had a better mouse trap for it
and I'm just loving that people are
finally waking up and seeing that so
that's fantastic but we've been doing it
for years and mug club we can only do it
because of you that's the model people
are going to is a mug Club type model
people that want to support and want to
do it but I just need you to know we've
been out there taking the hits on this
you knew it we knew it a bunch of other
people that are on the same team that
wear the same team jersey at the very
least have said that's not the way to go
and now they're coming around to it I'm
glad they're doing it better late than
never we do want all of these people to
succeed because we want voices for
conservatives to be loud and to be heard
by as many people as possible and not be
beholden to Big Tech and Stephen you've
been doing it for years you called it
I said I'm going to H the next pitch
ball right past the flly well good Lord
must have been
[Music]
with well thank you I have no idea to
whom you're referring but I like that
that's a baseball reference I really
like baseball I will say um baseball's
cool changed my mind I would have never
been happier to be wrong yeah yeah you
know this I always wish that I was wrong
where people would say hey they'll kill
us last yeah and uh it's it's pervasive
unfortunately on the conservative side
and by the way this is why we have the
YouTube dump button I want to reach
people where we can reach new people but
that has changed they've made it
impossible to reach new people with the
truth or you do but to a much smaller
degree so something that was really
exciting for us is to see the bulk of
our daily viewership move over to rumble
right move over to mug Club I mean if
you're going to be a brother in arms
with someone would you rather be someone
who's doing the bidding of YouTube meta
Facebook or the people people who
flipped the bird to the government of
France the people who flipped the bird
to uh you know par I was it was it was
it parliament in UK yeah in the UK as
well it's hard for me to keep track of
all the governments this been going on
for a long time um and by the way I know
that we have Sometimes some tech issues
and that's because so many of you tune
in and when you watch live with Rumble
so these things are not perfect those
things are being ironed out but long
time ago we decided hey we need to
uncouple I guess to use the term from
from Big Tech and um we said hey
hey this the the British are coming but
in this case it was you know big Tech uh
gender queer uh chain gangs we said
they're coming coming they're coming for
you people say no no we think we can
play ball and now a lot of people I
think you're going to see more of this
as we go into election
season hey we were removed immediately
before the last election yeah and I
think that a lot of other conservatives
are going to be facing that you can't
make up for it with sponsors you can
have some sponsors our sponsors are
long-term sponsors who we actually have
a relationship with yeah the the only
way to make it work is and and let me
just I want to say this because I really
am incredibly appreciative of of you and
mug Club but this is something that's
important to note sometimes I don't
always talk about the vision of it
because I feel like it's vulgar to
promote what is effectively the business
model but to be clear the business model
is you support what it is that you want
to see um there's a lot of fatigue tip
fatigue out there and you and I know
this where we have sometimes spoken with
people about perhaps coming into you
know mug Club and they go yeah but right
now I can make more and they'll site
patreon or GoFundMe or whatever it is we
go yeah but those can be those that that
valve can be pinched well if I combine
my revenue from YouTube and I combine my
Revenue here and what I'm going to make
on yeah but that can always go away yeah
and so I understand that for you as a
viewer right now there's so many places
to pay I mean not only is there like the
Netflix and peacock and the Hulu and
Disney and whatever else I don't know
what's where whether they do the uh the
Sylvester Stallone thing is it Paramount
but then you also have to go and hit a
tip jar for this creator that Creator at
the end you end up paying way more than
you did for traditional cable and what
we want to do is to give you enough
value where it's less than you know ends
up being about $7 a month along with
this mug and more shows that you want
that you were already watching anyway
not all of them will be home runs for
you not every show here will be for you
but our goal with every single new
signup is more content more impact and
more Independence we will never ever be
dependent on big Tech again if you see
these doors shutter at some point in
time and when it's curtains and that day
will come at some point it will be
because you decide that you don't want
to watch this anymore you decide that
the network that mug Club isn't
something that's a value and by the way
I'm okay with that we will never close
these doors because YouTube Facebook
meta or even Twitter X sorry it's hard
to know all these changing names say hey
you're not allowed a seat at the table
you decide if we stay or go and I would
much rather be serving you being
beholden to you than to some in
Palo Alto who probably says that we
should take
refugees while he has a spare bedroom so
if you're watching on YouTube head to
rumble if you're watching on Rumble
click this button right now you can join
mug club uh and uh continue watching
because it is chat Thursday Gerald thank
you very much we are going to see you on
mug club and mug club members of course
tomorrow another show piss off
YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
one